hello welcome to this video playing and
maradona okay let's go for what level of
un cadeau hmm c4 here i I don't know
exactly how this is played to be honest
okay let's go if or prevent any night f5
stuff okay it seems here once to all
night to have seven got some pressure on
the t file should be good I mean Bishop
h3 coming
I'd line that you play that doesn't have
a very good reputation with 85 and 90
for I can just take everything off there
I'll move the Queen Queen you to set a
little bit more dangerous maybe I Scott
bishop f8 coming maybe ok let's try if I
can weaken his King side a little bit
with night h4 if he decides to not move
the jeep on which is mm g5 is not a move
that you are particularly keen on
playing
okay III is covered it's important
so much I bring the hook back there now
let's take 20 40 is there something
better
the eighth got night well maybe he
doesn't have 95 I mean I can go out for
him I can go out for him why not he
takes it twice he takes it twice 49 h 3
check poor yes
okay maybe you can go Queen d7 now and
just simplify the whole thing but I'm
gambling a little bit that it doesn't my
queen d 7 is good all right then do it
now this looks interesting check some
queen's eggs one night x what's better
i takes probably and yeah yes he's
gotten out of it unfortunately
what a shame
what a shame I was just a nice position
yeah I know the deep on which I don't
see a big issue we threatening to take
here and that that I didn't pay any
attention I didn't I didn't see that
there anyway probably still not a big
problem
check
check
hmm ok he goes with the King I was
thinking maybe I can get a war on the H
file and invade
I want to go king d to King see 3 yeah
okay I have to give a pawn they're
probably but maybe I don't have to even
I can enter with the rook it's not a
problem here this position the F port is
also coming to play
I'm going to take that pawn and can't
come from behind with the rook check may
be here not giving him a tempo on the
sea far later
time warning I'd be here okay aid check
okay i can draw now but can I do more on
check holy not bra a third yeah probably
I also down on the clock I not resign oh
yeah I came at it was a bit of a shame
because I had an excellent position out
of the opening here with that age voyage
five and then that is nice check but
what I don't have is good development
maybe he's just about right to defend it
they have something better early on I
don't know chan is really just in time I
was thinking f forward that is not
working at all he can take twice him
check now giant here still he has this
annoyance is just equal i roped you
three also viewed unnecessary but i
don't think it's a big deal okay i think
a pretty correct drawdown thanks for
watching